how are you guys doing there have been
many legendary figures that have really
established themselves and left to Mark
in the Contemporary dower field of
course Ahmad is one of them and Zaki and
Ike is another but are we going to
continually see people like that being
developed well we're here in Norway with
our good old friend Fahad Qureshi how
are you brother okay tell us what is
this place man tell us is this a place
where you're going to be creating the
next generation of the art inshallah
that's really the the main aim of this
Center this Masjid in Norway that we're
establishing is to produce the art who
will take the level of dawah to the next
level so inshallah we want to see not
one but 10 30 so 40 50 60 Zakir Max
inshallah
so so the facility the area we're in
right now this will be the library
inshallah we'll fill these shelves with
books that the kids and the youth will
each other come and read and gain
knowledge about this it's really
beautiful I mean even if you just look
at the the red here is the
presentationally excellent presentation
you know and you can imagine putting
some you know manuscripts and coins or
something that will really Inspire I
think those individuals the students in
a classroom it's a beautiful environment
already this is what your donations are
doing ladies and gentlemen is it not yes
and let me show you the other facilities
as well yeah so this is one place which
is going to be used as a classroom as
you can see beautifully well lit
excellent presentation let's take a look
let's go upstairs wow there's an
upstairs fantastic and this is once
again this whole complex with the stairs
and up and down and all of this is the
donations of the people yes
all right so show me what's going on
here so this is martial art and we just
newly built all of this place wow this
is newly built with the money the
donations of the people yes
alhamdulillah fantastic and it's still
under construction but this will be the
studio this is the studio where we where
we will inshallah we're producing all of
the Islamic videos the lectures the
podcasts all of that inshallah will be
produced here amazing amazing and it's
you got your equipment all these
equipments are purchased as well with
the donations of the people so they're
not only purchasing these things they
approach they're investing in equipment
for a Muslim organization what a
fantastic thing show us a bit more yes
[Music]
this is just a meeting room beautiful
we've got a round table here you have
your meetings you know you have your
brainstorming sessions yes this room
we're going into right now is the main
office office this is where the research
is happening this is where we're
producing knowledge this is the main
research I think it's appropriate now to
introduce us to the shoes they did a
fantastic job and I spent some hours
many hours with them intrigued and
fascinated by as stimulated by their
conversation
he's being very modest trying to pretend
to see some work
brother how are you doing you're okay
are you okay yeah and you've been with
so we've fast for many years how do you
feel the role is for you
I cannot describe the feelings this is
the the work we are doing alhamdulillah
is for Allah
I'm very very blessed to be part of this
and I've been here from from the very
beginning as you have and I remember you
from how many years ago in other peace
conferences and I'll tell you what we're
blessed to have you as well and tell you
who else we're blessed to have this man
here is spent more than 10 years in
Saudi Arabia and Egypt combined
combining or collecting like a collector
a postgraduate after postgraduate you
know in Islamic Studies spending years
and years doing research brother how are
you doing okay
brother tell us something about the
research that you're doing and you've
got shyamala up here
I mean research is something which is so
extremely important for us to develop
intellectually as normal because if we
just go with whatever is there sometimes
it might not be enough we need to find
solutions to problems
is facing so many problems so many new
challenges so many things are happening
out there that we need to find solutions
for and that's a part of the console
that each day had isn't it to begin with
to find solutions for the woman you know
I've spoken he was inside this himself
but he's done some but who's some some
really interesting and deep research
I'm saying this and I've been in the
dial for many years myself it's Cutting
Edge and when it does come out it will
impact the entire Western Muslims
hemisphere in a way that honestly
anything else would have and just you
could even argue the whole Muslim world
and this is a knowledge production so
it's subhanallah you know the Hadith of
the Prophet Muhammad
we said already one of the things is
that everything ceases is interrupted
from the Amal of the Deeds of the child
of animal except three things we said is
one of them but one of the other ones is
that it's a beneficial knowledge which
people benefit from so imagine there's
two things in the of the three in the
Hadith that you can actually take
advantage of right now by just clicking
a link it's unbelievable to doing a
knowledge production cutting-edge stuff
with people that are not disqualified
but overqualified on the matter come on
and this is not just a message in a
dollar center it's a knowledge Hub
subhanallah I say that it's time it
really is high time no messing around
these opportunities cannot cannot we
missed out on click the link below it's
an amazing opportunity do it now
[Music]